Walgreens, the drugstore thats where you get
your condoms razors and give me
something else diaphragm diaphragms haha I don't know why I
said that! they have goes a long way yeah if
they have a fitting you gotta go to a
guy I got out and I have no idea I'm
coming to me
but alright I i'm waiting to hear your
Halloween have not Halloween candy
razors not heard I'm still not going to
Kaylee cheese-its if you wanna spend
eighteen dollars yeah I and all that
good stuff
the drugstore I think you know that
right robert reich wrote a piece in The
Huffington Post
talk about all these corporations that
are moving their corporate headquarters
all over the place
and Walgreens is among them they are
moving
their corporate headquarters to
Switzerland so all the time missus
I'm sorta summing up robert reich piece
here and if you get a few at-bats
you know about him fear complain that
american corporations are suffering
under a larger tax burden their foreign
competitors
the official corporate tax rate here is
.1 percent which is the highest but the
effective rate what corporations
actually pay after deductions is far
lower
in 2010 corporation headquartered in the
US paid a federal tax rate
I've thirteen-percent on their worldwide
income
so quickly a little bit more info about
Walgreens they're the largest drugstore
in the United States leave 8 at 1700
drug stores spread across the nation
and yet there about to move to
Switzerland we've got more info
so if they were to become a Swiss
corporation they will do
just as much business in the United
States not gonna change what they're
doing here
but they're just not gonna pay as much
in US acted the rest about to have to
make up for the different
which will probably cost taxpayers about
$4 billion over five years
this means more money for Walgreens
investors according top executives which
is why
large investors like those by both sober
Goldman Sachs
have bien pushing for it so we we got a
little more info before a
Blatter on a longer this is just the way
america is now right then it's a simple
as that
from Paul yeah everybody fuck from
parliament will we all are
I mean the from individuals on up but
that what Robert it right or rice I A
with their rights but
acting right quick I don't think I heard
right now and they're probably many
rival rightish
which I find him but no I didn't I said
ok but the point that he had made was
that if they're going to be doing that
that they can't have the same kind say
that they had as an american
corporations
on which is an excellent point break so
you can sit on both sides of the fence
right soviet go over their pay less in
taxes you're not allowed in with the
government the way that I have been
doing any given me a perfect segue
so in 2010 what we've got a special
provisions in the dodd-frank Act
limiting
the fees banks are allowed to charge
merchants for credit card transactions
resulting in a huge savings for that if
it became swift the day the special
provisions could be over
I think the 2010 election cycle
Walgreens political action committee
yeah
walgreens has the pac-10 has spent over
almost a million bucks on federal
election
if it comes with corporation it should
be allowed to spend a penny more again
if the morning
corroborate I assume that you are
agreeing with mister Asian means
I just want you know we've been talking
about patriotism and and being
pro-american into me this
you this is one example where we should
hold these corporations and companies
the CEO's accountable for being
anti-american I mean this dozen
this doesn't say I hope it does not
gonna sit right with a lot of americans
certainly doesn't sit right with me
on but you know for companies that are
making a tremendous amount of money
selling a fall bus that the drugs and
Halloween candy
they have to be able to share the burden
on the taxpayers and and
and for some reason in this country I
think the the right is gonna allow
Walgreens to
to do that some say that this is you how
can you impose them or stop them or take
your federal laws and what we're doing
and
this is a big problem right now and it's
going to result in higher taxes for
those people who are supporting it
right somebody has to make up for it
right you know the real irony here is
that if they
go to Switzerland they're still gonna
sell the shittiest chocolate
I but rather than start they're still
going to tell her she's animation it
yeah I'm not going to get a pedicure
gonna have gone on in this West stardom
by
alright wow that's a good plan Stan that
is a great way
party that corporations have just one so
a mark that nobody plays by any rules
whatsoever
look we had Mitt Romney running for
president a guy who admitted to having
all this money in the Cayman Islands
again not be legal so what they're doing
not my ego
on it but not but we have no ethical
standard so it as if
we couldn't find a guy to the
republicans couldn't find a guy to run
for president they didn't have money
fighting in another country
yeah but so is it that we just it's a
systemic we expect our marriage that
outcry to where is that outcry from his
own party that saying this is
unacceptable as an american you know
when we go back to you know the right
wing ski scandal iraqi gym on iraq
that happens in the white house only I i
absolutely agree I
its always baffled me that that that
republicans work against their best
interests and it happens all the time
when there
voting against their best interests and
you know for people who I
don't want to pay that much taxes then
you should hold the companies that are
making billions and billions or
trillions of dollars tonight
I'm wide open exactly right now cuddling
are they afraid of them
and some land afraid it's gonna bite
them back I think its meeting goes back
to this government
yes to stay outta stay outta my business
than my parents the same with
environment like that so much I wanted
out of my affairs and I want to hide my
money
fire when it comes to roads in school of
abortion and yeah it's you know those
kind
yeah map final thought on this is part
of this stuff when you talk about all
the money 7 corporations that
that there's just nothing sexy about
this topping so easier to talk about all
the other
like if you were if we were talking
about abortion people would get very
passionate
overtime at the death penalty or even
immigration but this kinda thing we talk
about taxes
accompany way to have no so it all
electricity could they are info and yes
if they if they maintain and influence
where they don't deserve an influence or
anything right wing influence anymore
that impact on those other sexy things
break so that makes this doubly
worse it's compounded that we don't we
don't talk about it because it's not
sexy and but then they influence dry
numbers
yeah you know but but it all million
dollars
all those numbers mean a lot yeah to
everyone's right
somebody sent me a picture when they had
a I Mitch McConnell wearing logo Zavala
piana
past lovers yeah companies that given
money and they said when it be great if
our
lawmakers were forced to put on the logo
in patches on the Jag
who's given them money like a NASCAR
race right my bad idea know it's a great
manager
yeah it's pretty good I mean that car
that's what they do they die because
extension and has covered a low as well
guess what our politicians
are exactly my same kelberg rain yeah I
was doing great night let's let's make a
movie for that